you know on some levels counter-strike
is a game of numbers and your health is
obviously one of the more important ones
when it hits zero your round is over but
with just one HP left you can make magic
happen
I mean who saves guns anyway right I'm
calling for the score eSports and today
we're talking about insane low health
plays and csgo now when we do talk about
death-defying plays in CS I'm sure a few
iconic moments do spring to mind so
let's get this week's best of
installments started with the most
famous low HP plays in csgo Sibley's
gonna be turning his back at the hunter
Waddell at the alley with the patient's
plate coming out flashbang is in there
now
25 seconds headshot coming in from
siblings what complain hell he do he
have to find the pawn and make his way
onto a site and look for the angle here
this is not easy ple way out in the open
e this is gonna be very difficult use
that like any time to work with a bomb
press could take five seconds alone he's
gonna go for it behind the fountain
scare games gonna charge him down is it
amiss quite a few pistol shots Kenny yes
he wanna kill punches around design it
well once again just be hiko about to
pull up yeah we've all we've got three
from behind quad Kenny find a fourth he
could support he's odd for the answer he
gets get right trying to
and 1v2 running up here p250 out jumping
and shooting he has one more kill
looking for these cutting hundred down
time is up oh my god are you kidding me
right in the nick of time and Navi are
gonna be sitting up quite literally on
the opposite side of the map and he is
just waving a flag saying come and get
me
seventeen points of help in a dream this
would be the a skull touch from full and
unbelieving a bit of a believer would
you suggest that you don't want to stop
believing but one you cast around okay
[Music]
forget saving the day for Navi but no
way no you know what guys defending or
retaking a site when you're playing CT
is stressful enough on its own but try
doing it with a glowing red health bar
Spiti hanging out over by humpty-dumpty
and they got Lola that's over by the APC
it's really a two dimensional attack how
long can he hang out he does big time I
thought he was only last a couple
seconds and he finally dies behind the
APC one-on-one situation but you are
ready oh my god is there enough time I
think there is Taz comes up massive
prick crossfire setup nothing with the
heroics there they've done a double peak
them and oh my god they might lose it
petti this is magical in response to
skadoodle he gets it
and just being taken hit by device
please not gonna get that one you free
picks up a nice what I want there's the
second kill 101 Oh free with one health
water clutch there from him
now it's rainin maikelele 2v4 here and
my clinic
to go down eventually Neal to finish it
off and it doesn't look possible here
rain gets three kills though and now one
bullet one but you're getting me rainy
picks up every single one and takes it
to overtime and is gonna come back and
turn it into double kill all his own one
HP on his person he still manages to
take down toe and that is with a
headshot one versus two are you kidding
me with one HP is he gonna make it
ace happen guys this is gonna be one for
the record books bomb is down on his
down my god he did it with 1 HP somebody
hello read it if I still alive one hit
point still takes now Pasha not anybody
just to get tossed - deep voice you are
on stoppable I'm able to take that one
Frank
that ball play is given the smoke that
stops it inhales right now echoed taking
down one that's just pulling who remains
here at least fresh gonna go down to him
to tech mines out the moment he gets
side control once again video does make
contact but it's not killed now they
know exactly where the AWP is but they
still don't deal with it well because
they walk in give cold the angle and he
goes and finds another one to get paging
me and AZ one from Maine and one from
Pop Tart cold with just the 8 HP looks
to be enough to shut them all down as
configs the next it'll be giving up the
awp due to the HP was the right call now
is definitely the right call what
performance that Western coach era now
guys on T side things can be even worse
not only are you working with the sliver
of health but you might have to take a
site all by your lonesome facing down
multiple enemies with a lot more health
than you have and that won't get them in
a two on three off the plot with n IP
players on full health and kneel on just
for now Sasha has to go pee she will
need over to where exist is coming from
Pitt Theo will get the headshot - what's
exist for health points is plenty for a
player life
big forehead shut up different flare
neos for help wasn't gonna be tested now
by forest Warlow - two of these biggest
players to the cab
killing us Tara tries to move in he's
got any careful nor utility they've
already jumped on to the bomb here this
is gonna be a miracle shot
[Music]
as recently picked up by any ISM he has
proven to be way too much for cloud nine
put are they though are they sean gares
does win it in the end what a
back-and-forth Brown that's just rush
any weapon he can take away at this
point is perfect there's one goes for
the second transfers the headshot on now
he's got the bomb and a chance but only
one HP this would have to be miraculous
for rush to convert this fraud and he's
still when eyes are going to come in
from the flight 1hp he's gonna go back
to the Pete down but on a to plays she's
gonna do it one HP this is in position
the monitors going down that a force
drops away from the very tight positions
but he's full of opportunity one because
Oh Forrester is completely unawares so
the podcast we had and the rifle and
it's Ross
Oh No was gonna bounce and he would die
I'll be plays up the smoke brilliantly
that's the first kill for him the second
player looks like he might go down as
well these very low ropes with the
clutch you know I look at the trying to
duck out fast as he can
speeding on through up through connector
oh come on he's gonna try and play this
one and smart at all bit by just played
himself happy make you this way and a
very very slowly up through cable you
watch you through double doors and I
think he's a wet out that's why the
Rowlett hasn't crossed himself so much
space by just playing a really quick
fate toward the beast sight now he's at
the point down a he's gonna wait for a
happy to walk like in the anti-noise he
has to be perfect or as Shaun Tait each
piece he's lost the angle though he's
nearly stuck in beside the APC happy
knows exactly where he is he's gonna go
up football and here's dick what i watch
pulling it back for kills in the round
three of which come with eight HP in a
one versus three he's got 20 HP you get
the bumps planted for him plus you
realize it'll commit to it just yet let
me pop this going for the ak-47 oh yeah
I mean this is one bullet and every
player Lowell brings it in to a
one-on-one and the jump spots keep out
who's got his pistol and Louis now got
to be very careful that's nice timing
for the pecan Keith Jellicle Toby's
Metta World Peace changer be with the
subtlety
[Music]
my god I don't want to cast this anymore
Lucas brings it down to just nvk and now
that 8 HP that secondary peak from the
boost it could come to haunt them
because it's all that remains for nvs
he's got the ak-47 it's a saving grace
in the blank spots the low HP toward
highway as well Lucas Falls bomb down in
front smokes
according to pick that up at least to
get the ball down flashover he wants to
get aggressive knows he pushed up gets
his back turn and clutches it back for
envyus to tie the game really
intelligent smart mmm BK low HP you can
see the awareness of him hey I have to
try and pick together walks he gets in
the back like the front row coming
through Happy's the left man left
standing p250 in half roams around tries
to get the drop of zero oh shut up RP
forces it into overtime
he spawned it as well the port side so
there could be expecting this this is
really smart play from Flushing and
drawn their attention over that bump is
used to take it's actual getting really
late in the game here if he can just
take his time kills this guy it's
dropped on the incredible play from
Flushing here
absolute god it looks like liquid will
keep their head above water
we'll pay the Vice the auto submerge
them once again play second fiddle to
this blonde one flashes walk over
towards highway spot small players that
he's gonna get the frag is on one health
since the one HP dream real wants more
he's picked up three kills taco huge
advantage in terms of HP reason I can
approach that device is gonna get it
done I think yet one of these kills
beginning it really does hurt 5-3 body
and next time I'm gonna be playing this
one aggressively you know facing I'll
have the first practice noodle water
there on 15 health is neo gonna do it
again he's put so many from this cover
six seven volts the U of T's gotta push
40 fighting to the headshot one HP and
thankfully he doesn't cross into the
crosshairs of its well there's narrowly
dodging these through the boxes this
would be huge for optic and mixels gonna
switched on but again one HP that is
nicely done at leash and I think this
ascertain if there's anyone close to the
stage you can grab the pawn fullback I
think it's just enough to deep its oh
nice bunny hop I have to say from
Fryeburg you knows the AWP silly steps
for Jordan if this shot on C's he'll get
away they're both there he knows it now
but it's low HP eight seconds he's gonna
go for the plant he commits to it rather
than facing off against flamey the
Molotov we go back out to hold him off
now it's the way tree and Freiburg is
done at a scotch for the man pronax he's
still here though and he's going for
more to big Frank's the third man is
here offer
stay alignment is gonna be great
oh he picks up a quad kill he could do
even better than staying alive he wants
that ace and that would be absolutely
brutal and I say that Krueger Reed he
walked in Fryeburg comes in he sprays
just hitting the palm down he's gonna
have to take the fight
shrouded 20hp will we see it it gets one
headshot he gets a second round the sky
sure health is just shutting down the
dreams of winter Fox and I think you
just saw blushes like no he's up there
but no look there's gonna be a full peak
coming out there from slummy and they
just lethal and below you gonna sit
inside are you that throws the pistol on
that weird look he'll nicely done by
flusher and still have enough vision to
win the exchange and the round I would
say fashion is SK or do they oh my
goodness automatic for HP lights two
kills it's all for naught perhaps or is
it because schedule is actually going on
undetected they put so much effort in
the Daigle oh my god automatic another
and they win the round off that you have
to be kidding me that is the most insane
round a deagle has had yet in this
tournament
[Music]
the bomb we've got 141 HP combined hello
Jake yes are you awake hello
what was that 25 seconds and now
automatic has brought this into a one
person what a god tier play 1 V 3 clutch
7 HP makes it happen well guys that's
all we got via this week on best stuff
now if your favorite low HP csgo played
did not make this compilation I don't
know what to tell you
go make your own video or something see
you next week thanks for watching if you
want more great content just like this
be sure to hit the subscribe button